[Applaudissements]
dans le québec des années 60
des groupes comme les baronets les
classels l'issue le temps et césar et
les romains faisaient tourner les têtes
[Musique]
cette fabuleuse époque du loyer est
racontée dans le documentaire intitulé
double boxe on me raconte un peu
toujours la même histoire de la chanson
québécoise à partir de félix leclerc les
chansonniers charlebois tout ça et on
n'avait jamais raconter l'histoire a
fait des débuts du showbiz ben c'est là
que j'ai compris je serai pas besoin
d'un chantage fait dès le début du
showbiz québécois sont intrinsèquement
liés aux producteurs de l'espèce ce roi
du 45 tours a vendu 4 millions de
disques dans les années 60
à un certain moment ces succès occupait
80% des palmarès 12 box et surtout son
histoire dernier s'exécute à dans une
toune sap à une demie quand on va
trouver une la gaming par l'ong seront
encore là dessus quand c'est bon ça va
quand c'est pas bon ça va moins comme
celle chant jean bien pas parce que j'ai
pas gêner la mauvaise à l'écouté
chaînage d'un studio on a 25 p
je pense par de susciter samus est en
bon état
[Musique]
à l'aide de belles trouvailles dans les
archives du box est un voyage dans le
temps
[Musique]
en fait une grosse recherche au niveau
des archives on voit à renée martel qui
était en train de se faire brosser les
cheveux par son père marcel martel mais
quand on est tombé la science et aux
malades
c'est des images qui étaient oubliés à
bibliothèque et archives nationales
il y a
le documentaire jukebox prendra
l'affiché le 4 septembre
[Musique]
oui ces dépouilles mais radio-canada bon
rien